good afternoon and many thanks for being
here
I am Ernesto Zedillo director of the
Center for the Study of globalization I
am very very pleased to welcome
professor Stig never since key to a
university I was with professor
Burzynski last fall at a meeting in st.
Petersburg Russia and was very much
impressed at the time by his sharp
analysis of the dilemmas confronted by
American foreign policy in this era
characterized by globalization but also
by Yuke's the position of American power
and unprecedented threats to its
security actually I had the privilege of
listening to a very interesting debate
he got with Henry Kissinger and I must
say and Henry knows that I have said
that that you want that debate that day
I don't know you have lost others with
him but that day you want
well considering the pertinence of
professor Burzynski's work for our
centers own activities
I immediately extended him an invitation
to visit our university an invitation
that he offered to consider positively
rather soon we are very fortunate that
today is not only honoring that
invitation but that it is done at a time
when professor ever since his newest
book has just been published just a few
weeks ago the choice global domination
or global leadership was published by
basic books so the idea is to have a
presentation on these books central
thesis by Professor Burzynski
himself and then proceeded to an open
discussion starting with comments by
Professor Bruce Ackerman of the North
School who has very kindly accepted to
make some comments
professor Burzynski who earned a PhD
from Harvard nobody is perfect professor
Kaczynski has had a very distinguished
career in which academia and public
service had blended to produce a truly
unique expertise on American foreign
policy and global politics he has been
on the faculty of Harvard Columbia and
Johns Hopkins and was of course national
security adviser to President Carter
professor Brzezinski is a very prolific
author who has the service Lee received
numerous academic and civic distinctions
please dear friends let's welcome
professor versine ski
president Zillow professor Ackerman
ladies and gentlemen it is true that him
I was educated at Harvard but I want you
to know that I got engaged as a
consequence of the Harvard Yale football
game so there are some possibilities for
redemption in life and I want to use
this occasion not so much as to
summarize my book but more to share with
you two propositions which arise out of
the book but which reflect my grave
concern about America's role in the
world today and these two propositions
and the following the first is that at
this juncture of history I'm deeply
concerned that particularly in the wake
of 9/11 American policy worldwide is
guided by a fundamental miss diagnosis
demagogic Lee proclaimed regarding the
defining challenge of our time and
second that in that context there is the
risk that America may become bogged down
in a huge Jewish strategic quicksand and
the first concern the misdiagnosis is
already producing widespread isolation
of the United States around the world
and a growing crisis of credibility of
the United States the second if the
conditions should deteriorate could
indeed jeopardize American global power
so let me talk a little bit to both of
these propositions and then share some
conclusions or implications that I draw
therefrom with regards to the first
proposition the misdiagnosis I'm very
troubled by the fact
that we are essentially adopting a
rather vague emotional semi theological
definition of the central global menace
that we're facing and as a consequence
we are finding it difficult fully to
comprehend what is the defining novelty
of our time of what is producing the
fundamental change in our time which I
submit to you is essentially that of a
massive unprecedented global political
awakening that is generating in its wake
a great deal of political turmoil of
which terror is a manifestation as well
as a symptom but the broader phenomenon
the wider phenomenon there people that
the global political awakening is
generating is the decisive manifestation
of our time it is unprecedented we have
never had a situation worldwide in which
the majority of the world's population
is being politically activated
throughout history most people have been
politically passive political activism
has been a minority phenomenon now it is
increasingly a global reality produced
obviously by literacy and the spread of
literacy by the impact of TV which
produces intimacy by the internet all of
which creates aspirations unrest indeed
turmoil much of that is abetted in my
view by the ongoing globalization which
forces changes in societies regarding
regardless of their readiness for such
changes quality same time escalating
expectations and we that is to say
America is the principal vehicle of this
globalization we are economically
intrusive were culturally seductive but
the unsaid
impact of America in the world works at
cross-purposes with America's interest
of the number one global power in
international stability our seductive
impact generates Envy resentment indeed
widespread suspicions regarding the real
motives of globalization with many
viewing it increasingly as selfish I
rather fear in fact that the existing
doctrinal vacuum in the world may soon
be filled by a comprehensive doctrine
that merges anti-americanism with
antique globalization the 20th century
was a century of ideological conflict
and communism Marxism clearly was the
most important doctrine of that century
that doctrine failed it's been refuted
by experience it degenerate into a crime
but a doctrine vacuum that exists today
could be filled by a new doctrine whose
emotive power would be resentment and
envy and fear and a sense of
powerlessness producer Montaigne Slee by
a combination of anti-americanism an
anti globalization and you can see some
of these stirrings of such a doctrine in
the writings of a number of political
sociologists political philosophers some
in this country some particularly in
Europe and that could become a potent
brew globally now in that context of
course there's also terrorism as a
special manifestation but we have to
recognize what it is and not exaggerate
also what it is it is a technique of
conflict an ugly technique of conflict
in a brutal technique of conflict and
it's dangerous but it is bred by the
objective and subjective historical and
political conditions in specific and
diverse parts of the world it is not a
universal reality which is identical
which can be defined
as terrorism with a global reach and the
answer to it can also not be simply a
declaration of war on terrorism with a
global reach terrorism can be dangerous
we've wedded to weapons of mass
destruction it can be an extremely
potent destructive force but it
manifests itself in different ways
directs itself against different targets
and it has different specific motifs now
in that context we as a people we as a
nation we as the power in the world have
to recognize that henceforth insecurity
is going to be the national reality the
days of national security
sovereign security are over done and
they will not come back we are joining
the world in that new reality because in
modern times no one had true
national security genuine
invulnerability except innocence we
today that's finished and therefore it
follows from that that the global
security has to be a key element of our
quest for national security and global
security means a seamless web of
expanding interdependence and it's an
our interest not to undermine it but to
institutionalize it and yet I'm
concerned that our current policy and
particularly the way we diagnose our
global reality may in fact increase the
probability of sporadic terror attacks
on the United States there was an
article within last week in the New York
Times some of you might have read it
called a leaner meaner jihad and one of
the key points it makes is that since
the action in Iraq more terrorist groups
have been proliferated and there is
wider
global recruitment for anti-american
jihad in different parts of the world
this is also the judgment of the
International Institute for Strategic
Studies I do not believe that we can
respond to this problem simply by catchy
simplistic soundbites about evil or
nonsensical statements uttered at the
highest level to the effect that and I
quote and some of you may recognize this
quote we love things they hate things
whatever that means yeah I think at some
point we have a national obligation at
the highest level to ask seriously who
are the terrorists and where do they
come from
who are the terrorists and where do they
come from it's not some global
phenomenon
the president spoke just a few days ago
on the first anniversary of the war he
spoke again about the collision between
us and the global evil of terror and he
said there can be no peace between us
and terror if you substitute Nazism or
communism for the word terror in these
statements it makes a great deal of
sense because these were powers we knew
who they were we knew who were fighting
but these generalized vague statements
don't identify with the enemies they
don't tell us who he is and why he is
the enemy if we in brief don't recognize
the complexity of the phenomenon of
global political awakening and in that
context we do not address the
specificity of the terror that manifests
itself we can neither tackle it nor
engage others in a collective effort to
approve it Cheney spoke the other day
about terrorism and he said the
following terrorism and I'm not calling
again
is not directed at any one government or
nation or religion but against all
governments nations
and people I am not sure that this
describes adequately for example at the
terrorists in Kashmir who as far as I
know have no special gripe against
missing Mexico but they have a gripe
against the Indian government I don't
think it explains the terrorists in
Palestine who are not fighting Norway
but do dislike intensely their visit
with the State of Israel
I don't think tells us anything about
the terrorists in Ulster were not
conducting warfare against Thailand but
who have a particular gripe against the
British government if we do not know who
they are where they come from we not
only find more difficult to extirpate
them we'll find it impossible to
undercut them politically and socially
it's as if someone was talking about
waging war against lung cancer without
ever once mentioning smoking or tobacco
we have to know the symptoms the
pathology the roots of the problem and
only then can we combine the necessary
force to deal that specific aspect of
the global turmoil and political means
to isolate it but more broadly on then
can we collectively address the larger
challenge of global instability and that
brings me to my second proposition
namely that we now may find it very
difficult in this context to address
effectively the colossal strategic
challenge that we have assumed in the
wake of 9/11 and that challenge arises
in a huge area of the world spanning the
region from Suez to cynjohn from the
southern frontier of Russia all the way
to the shores of Pakistan on the Indian
Ocean five hundred and fifty million
people live in that area and we are now
plunged headlong into that region we are
engaged who engaged militarily we are
engaged politically and that region
I called the global Balkans because it
is like the Balkans of Europe of the
19th century internally conflicted with
a suction effect on global powers to
come in and to become absorbed that is
what is happening this huge region it is
religiously inflamed ethnically
conflicted densely populated
demographically explosive massively poor
but rich in energy control the larvae
which gives whoever has that control and
normos leverage both in Western Europe
and the Far East we are engaged we're
gonna be engaged for a long time to come
but the question is can we handle it on
our own do we have the men and the money
and the blood and the will to be engaged
alone I fear that if we look at the
scale and complexity the problems the
answer is that we probably do not and
yet we have to be engaged in creating
stability in Afghanistan and Pakistan
because the two issues are not one and
that's a huge monumental problem just
think of the scale those countries and
the depth of complexity of these
countries we have to deal with the Iran
which is a serious country with a
genuine tradition and national
aspirations in 70 million people and
which impacts on Afghanistan and we have
to overcome the instability the residual
instability in the wake of the war in
Iraq 25 million people passionate
increasingly volatile on whom Iran again
also has an influence and we have to
deal with israeli-palestinian problem
which so inflames public opinion in the
Middle East and without progress towards
peace in that issue there can be no
American extraction from Iraq imagine us
leaving Iraq the israeli-palestinian
conflict involves continued spilling of
blood and mutual violence
any resulting government in Iraq after
we have left will be anti-american an
anti-israeli in brief the four problems
have enumerated require progressive
resolution if any one of them is to be
resolved and that is a monumental
undertaking which I don't think we can
pursue in our own we need friends and we
need particularly Europe which has the
money and the men and the proximity and
the historical interest and even the
historical experience the region is
important to Europe it's also important
incidentally to Japan marginally to
China we need Europe as a partner
therefore we need a Europe and the
unification of Europe is in our interest
because it increases the probabilities
of Europe becoming more engaged globally
whereas it divided Europe we clear up is
going to be passive and indifferent but
that means attaching importance to
enduring alliances and not toying with
the fashionable slogan of coalition's of
the Willing which tend to be expedient
and opportunistic
we have to be willing to accept Europe
as a partner but that means recognizing
also the reality of Europe and
attempting to engage it what follows
from my brief statement of these two
dilemmas and my expression of concern
the first is that we cannot prevail in
responding to the challenges of global
turmoil terrorist outbreaks regional and
rest without enduring alliances in
particular with Europe based on
conviction and convenience and an
increasingly shared strategic vision we
will not create that shared vision if we
say to our friends as we have been
saying over the last year and a half
over and over again if you're not with
us you're against us we have been saying
that at the highest level
over and over again I strongly suspect
that the person who's using a phrase and
you know whom I mean does not know that
that phrase originates with a very
particularly significant historical
figure
Lenin Lenin is the one who coined that
phrase in order to justify the
elimination of the Mensheviks he was the
one who proclaimed the or not with me
you're against me you will not create
the genuine Alliance in the basis of
formula you can only create it in the
basis of a serious strategic dialogue
and a serious strategic dialogue is not
dictation slogans or demagoguery it is
an attempt to formulate a shared
perspective on complex issues and you
cannot do that simply by focusing on a
specter by creating anxiety by creating
the impression that we are in effect
faced with some sort of a global
overriding specter that threatens us
from every angle we have to talk about
shared dilemmas and we have to talk
about shared responses we have to use
NATO increasingly as an instrument of
shared decision-making that leads me to
my second implication namely that we
cannot have in effect a shared policy if
we confuse a global obsession with a
global strategy if we think that
preponderance is the same thing as
omnipotence that if we ignore the loss
of credibility that we have already
suffered and the loss of credibility is
a very very major cost effect it makes
it more difficult to elicit support I
often like to quote the example of the
Cuban Missile Crisis which occurred
before many in this room were born but
some of you in this room might even
remember it President Kennedy sent Dean
Acheson to France to the goal to tell
him their Soviet missiles with nuclear
weapons targeted on the United States
and Cuba if they're not removed we'll
take them out if we take them out
there's going to be nuclear war
but we have no choice and after Addison
finished telling the goal that he said
to the goal and now I want to show you
the evidence which I brought with me do
you know the goals answer I do not wish
to see the evidence the word of the
President of the United States has good
enough from me go back and tell him
friend stands with the United States do
you think that would happen today if an
emissary went somewhere and said we have
information that Iran has weapons of
mass destruction for example we're going
to attack it I rather suspect people
would say let's see the evidence and
leave it behind so we can carefully
examine it loss of credibility is a cost
effective I'm also struck by the fact
incidentally on this issue that we've
been allegedly misled for example in
Niger uranium business for Iraq it's
kind of curious that having said that
we've been mislead we haven't asked who
has misled us and why we found out that
this information came from the british
i've been some timid inquiries where did
you get this information they have said
from the italians yeah
well perhaps it might be a good idea to
ask the italians where did you get it
unless you fabricated it i would like to
know who was spinning us were the
foreign intelligence services that
contributed information that resulted in
us losing our credibility connected with
that it's another implication namely
that if we want to prevail and if we
want to get europe to deal with us we
have to be very careful to avoid
stigmatizing the world of islam so it
doesn't become against us in toto and
that we have to address some of the more
immediate problems of the Middle East
because most of the terrorists that go
after us originate from the Middle East
largely for three sort of me emotive
reasons the fact that were the
inheritors of the prank of British
colonial roll the fact that we have been
in Saudi Arabia close to the sacred
sites of Islam that I would
the Wahabis and the fact that we have
been engaged indirectly in the
israeli-palestinian conflict and
proceeded by the Arabs as partial to
Israel unless we address these problems
we can't cope and the Europeans feel
strongly that a neutral American
position on the israeli-palestinian
conflict is a de facto partial position
which in effect backs the much the
stronger party and we have been very
reluctant to go beyond vague
formulations either about the
desirability of abstinence from violence
or about the ultimate desirability of
peace without being willing to say what
that piece ought to look like
and the fact is that the parties to the
conflict the Israelis and the
Palestinians are not capable of
formulating a peace concept or
negotiating in good faith each other
because so they say they so intensely
dislike each other and distrust each
other and therefore it has to be an
outside party that begins to formulate
some sort of a concept in detail of
peace in the expectation and hope that
the more moderate elements in the public
opinions of both Israelis and the
Palestinians will begin to see the
benefits of a peace once they know what
it will look like we have articulated
the idea of the roadmap to a vague
destination which is two states but
otherwise undefined where exactly they
are what is their shape and that is a
formula for each to distrust the other
and to try to trip up the other on the
way quote-unquote towards peace on this
roadmap if we begin to articulate what
the outline real outline of peace is we
can begin to mobilize political support
for peace and there is an outline namely
the Geneva Accords negotiated in detail
by Israelis and Palestinians on a
private basis about 50 pages of detail
involving a very very deliberate and
complicated formula balancing the
interests of both and producing an
arrangement which has the potential
for being the basis for an enduring
peace if the United States and our
European allies were prepared to say
that the roadmap eventually leads to no
outcome like this we would increase the
chances that in both Israel and the
Palestinians there will be a greater
inclination to view peace as an
alternative to what is happening right
now otherwise each is locked into a
setting of a paralyzed commitment to
escalating violence with no good outcome
in sight and with the one quite possible
outcome for us namely that some of the
violence will now be transposed to the
United States
and we have seen already prognosis to
that effect in the light of what
happened last week another implication
that I draw from all of this is that we
cannot deal effectively with the
problems I've been mentioning without
decent intelligence and we don't have
decent intelligence the events of the
last year have shown that on some key
issues we are in effect close to being
blind we should have been able to
permeate Iraq and to know what it has
and what it does not have it was not a
closed country like North Korea or the
Soviet Union or China and yet we didn't
and this I believe shows a major failure
and this puts a major question mark on
the policy of preemption to which we
have dedicated ourselves because a
policy of preemption implies a
pre-emptive attack on someone else
because we know what that someone else
is about to do to us and that means
knowledge that means intelligence but if
you don't have intelligence then the
policy of preemption is a doctrine of
preemption on suspicion and the doctrine
of preemption and suspicion is a formula
for an international law of the jungle
for global instability and hence
improving our intelligence and
particularly improving our human
intelligence in
central priority intelligence is the
Achilles heel of our security
how much rather spend one dollar
intelligence than ten dollars in
Homeland Security in order to be more
secure and incidentally I would also
like to see an independent DCI appointed
for a fixed term and not politically
appointed by different presidents and my
final point and I'll stop at this stage
is that our policy over the last 40
years or so has been successful because
it has been a policy based on moderation
on consensus ultimately and
bipartisanship this is the first time we
have a policy which is based on
extremism and I say this as someone who
is not partisan when it comes to foreign
policy I have supported several
Republican presidents I tend to make my
judgment on presidents largely in terms
of national security
domestically I am a Democrat this is the
first time with a policy based on
extremism
I don't want it followed incidentally by
another policy base of extremism of the
left I think both the left and the right
other extremes cannot deal with global
problems I would like to see us return
to bipartisan foreign policy because
only then will we have the intellectual
basis the philosophical vision to
address the more complex to Goble
problems a very specific way of
returning to my partisanship would be
for the next president to appoint
someone from the opposite party to be a
Secretary of State and I've said this
publicly on national television I'd like
to see curry if he's elected president
appoint the chairman of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee senator
lugar as Secretary of State or if he
wants to be bolder than that senator
Hagel I would like to see George Bush if
he's re-elected appoint senator
Lieberman a secretary of state who
instead supported him on the war in Iraq
so he ought to be continued and if he
wants to be more daring he could go for
senator Biden the point is a return to
bipartisanship is essential
if we are able to deal with the two
problems that I have tried to share with
you how do we define the nature of our
time how do we deal with the strategic
dilemma into which we are now deeply
engaged let me finish by quoting a short
passage from a letter I got recently
it's a letter from European it was
native tongue as you will see it's not
English he describes himself as an
elderly person I read it with curiosity
because it opens with a series of
extremely flowery compliments addressed
to me so naturally I was interested but
I was also a little suspicious I said
probably he wants something from me and
my vanity is not under such control as
to deny myself the pleasure of reading
one or two words about myself - you have
to see what caught my attention and
described as a man of conscience
statesmen a great strategist Co
architect of American power
so I read on although a little
suspicious but this is what he said this
is what he said in a letter you will
surely agree with me this is a person I
don't know you will surely agree with me
that as history teaches the great powers
usually collapsed not because of their
weakness but paradoxically because of
their strength strength makes for
arrogance arrogance makes for blindness
and blindness does not permit one to see
all real potential or even hypothetical
dangers menaces perils risks and threats
it does not permit one to see and
identify them early enough clearly
enough and correctly enough the great
powers collapsed when they had reached
the peak of their strength when they
were at the peak of their economic
political or military abilities
capabilities or possibilities they
always collapsed when their actions
endeavors and
undertakings were not harmonized or
synchronized with the quality of their
time not only does America need America
the world needs America the world truly
does need America to be strong and
powerful although not necessarily
warlike and belligerent thank you very
much
Thank You professor Pierzynski for that
excellent lecture you I guess you are
like the good French wine and wines or
should I say Polish wines you are
getting better with experience and now
we will have professor Ackerman the law
school who doesn't need any introduction
and making some comments and then we'll
open the floor for discussion thanks a
lot the first and most important thing
to say is this is a very good book and
you know I've read of course there
there's been this enormous outpouring of
stuff and for one reason or other I've
read maybe six or seven percent of it
that means a hundred and twenty books or
something like that and this is one of
the best and I recommend it in
conjunction with another book by John
ikenberry after victory and because I
see these two books as two halves of a
coin for obvious reasons the I agree
with really III I'll point to a couple
of disagreements but I basically agree
with Brzezinski's main points especially
about Europe especially about the
silliness he has a great line which I
much admire saying it's like in 1939
declaring war against the Blitzkrieg
it's just a technique and we have to
think politically and from his point of
view militarily but the thing called a
weakness of this book but the part the
thing that doesn't talk about its
institutional imagination creation of
new institutions gestures toward the end
you know to a reorganization but of NATO
of existing forms of collaboration
between your
the United States and that's important
but that is not enough
the we have to it's it's that the
tragedy of all this war talk is that it
is putting the great power in this weird
position of rather than creating new
forms of international law of becoming
an outlaw this is crazy
generally speaking the powerful you know
shaped law so as to and that's the
Eikenberry reference to expressed there
its ideals and of course that's
precisely what happens in 1945 the one
things I just is I would say even a
weakness but certainly a striking fact
about this book is that it mentions
United Nations only once and in a
dismissive way really the the United
Nations not an organization the United
Nations is a treaty ratified by the
Senate of the United States and under
article 6 of the Constitution is part of
the supreme law of the United States
it isn't vague international law it is
the supreme law of the United States and
it is fundamental to understand as the
this generation of national security
thinkers do not but the last generation
did that the foreign policy the United
States has to be based on the rule of
law by which I mean the rule of American
law which is the United Nations Charter
it is I quite agree with professor
Pierzynski that the doctrine of
prevention or preemption or whatever we
want to call it has very a variety of
institutional presuppositions which it
will take us a decade or two even
apropos to approximate all these Russian
speakers have to learn Arabic I mean
there are a lot of things that would
have to go on
but it's just illegal though at the
present time under the law of the United
States to endorse the president strategy
the president's president strategy is
against the United Nations Charter not
talking we're not talking about the
casuistry of the Iraqi war but the
doctrine that we can on suspicion even
well justified suspicion invade
countries that aren't at the very least
invading us or posing a clear and
present danger of such is just a
violation of American law and but that's
really the pose the point which is to
say how are we going to change and
restructure the law for the 21st century
that's the question both at home and
abroad and I just have a couple of I'm I
had just have a couple of thoughts on
this the Terrorism of course is two very
different problems they are taught there
are problems of terror States rogues
aggressive States which are and then
there are then there are non-state
actors and this absolutely no reason to
think that in 15 years the terrorists
will be Islamic they might be living in
Montana they might be living in Mexico
there this is you know there are six
billion people in the world and there is
always going to be a lot of people who
hate the hegemon and the balance of
Technology has shifted and there will be
events like September 11th once in a
while whatever we do so now the first
institutional challenge domestically is
to prevent the president to demagogue
every time such a thing happens and pass
a new Patriot Act every time it happens
how to do this and that is we have to
we have to create a new legal framework
in the United States which permits the
President of the United States to go in
front of the TV and and not say after
the next terrorists large terrorist
right but this is a war which is the
word Wars anti institutional creativity
and so I've been working quite a bit
recently on the idea that he should get
up there and say this is a temporary
state of emergency and how to define a
set of powers for for us domestically to
take effective action in the short term
without endangering our civil liberties
in the long term is the first problem
I'll just give you one part of a
solution which is that every two months
it's called the supermajority Rhian
escalator every two months Congress has
to reauthorize the state of American see
with increasing percentages of
majorities from 50 to 60 to 70 to 80
percent thereby assuring under couldn't
have normal predictably that it will
come to an end in contrast to what is
likely to occur with this permanent war
permanent against in defined terrorism
and then internationally and this hooks
up to speaks first and most fundamental
point which is the world away point we
need a set of institutions a new set of
institutions and ideals that will not
only respond to the problems of the
global Balkans but which will inspire
all people of the world to associate
with Western ideals and institutions and
when we take on the if we don't we have
to use United Nations changing our
nation's reconstruct a credible form of
liberal democratic internationalism the
this is of course it's
sort of visionary in the present moment
but it has to be done if for no other
reason that big is perfectly right that
we are totally incapable of managing the
global Balkans on our own we have to
recognize I think that the United States
of America is not going to solve the
israel-palestine problem I would sign on
the dotted line but it's not going to
happen
it's not going to happen under a
Republican administration and it's not
gonna happen under a Democratic
administration the and and so this how
are we going to Matt we can if that's
true and let's assume I may be wrong I
hope I'm wrong but it's assumed that I'm
right well then to manage the
tremendously various problems of the
global Balkans so will require new forms
of international legitimated increment
which we are not the only actor
is that right now there are certain
problems which are reading very
immediate and serious and what I agree
with you of the need for a new burst of
institutional creativity the fact of the
matter is that if we can engage others
in responding effectively to the
challenge of the global Balkans we will
be initiating the process of creating
these new solutions and I would hope
that out of an intelligent response to
the problem that we confront the main
the come as a consequence the new burst
of institutional cooperation I talked a
little bit in my book for example of the
need to expand the structure of security
just from Europe to Asia
indeed even of turning OSCE which is
organisation of Security and Cooperation
for Europe into an organisation of
security cooperation for Eurasia and get
the Chinese involved in it and get the
Japanese involved I think we should
expand the g8 which is an anomaly now
because is supposed to be a summit of
the industrial democracies but it has a
Russian unit in which occasionally might
as well have China in it we might as
well have India in it so there are
institutional initiatives wouldn't be
taken I argue in my book but we will not
be able to engage in a large-scale
architecture unless we have first a more
rational diagnosis of the historical
well thank you all right well that's
very interesting comment why don't you
generalize it a little more and say for
example that the root of the problem
in Northern Ireland is militant
Christian terrorism or militant Catholic
terrorism yeah I don't know what
religion the basics are but I suppose
you could find some definition that fits
Christianity into it and so forth and so
forth and then you can go on and ask
yourself if you do that what are the
likely consequences there is such a
thing as a self-fulfilling prophecy and
you begin to generalize the phenomenon
you talk about militant Islamist
terrorism well first of all not all
terrorists in the world are Islamic
second villain or are all dismissed
terrorists in the vast majority of this
not
world is not engaged in terrorism some
of them are very fundamentalist
incidentally if you look at this magnet
world which spans the globe from Nigeria
to Borneo there are number of Islamic
societies that are very fundamentalist
but they're not terrorists terrorism may
be infused with religious zeal in some
cases but it also has very specific
territorial historical and political
roots and I think it's not interest to
identify them but not to generalize them
and we don't generalize it but talk
about terrorism as some sort of
universal evil then you really got the
pressing problem as Professor Ackerman
cited from my book that's like saying
world war two was not against Hitler in
the Nazis was against blitzkrieg you
know terrorism is a technique for
killing people it's a technique for
intimidating people but it doesn't tell
you anything about bigoted terrorists
are unless and until you look more
closely you have to be more specific
these kinds of sweeping generalizations
are either escapism on the part of the
ignorant or a deliberate effort to get
us involved in the world of Islam on the
part of the more knowledgeable that also
devious
due to display should be renewed and
invite employees sitting to talk about
advocating global security which you
comment on what you envision that
failing
we go buddy Global Security Corporation
has Patriot Act it's legislation within
the United States designed to enhance
the capacity of the executive branch of
the government to deal with actual
potential terrorism panting professor
laughs Renee knows much more about this
than I do but I who touched on that
issue in my book and I expressed some
concerns over the fact that the
atmosphere in which the paper has been
adopted is in some respects reminiscent
with other carriers in American history
in which we adopted various actions to
enhance our security but that would
subsequently we weren't particularly
proud I've been lying I'm a garthe ISM
I've in mind the deportation of the
Japanese I have in mind the Espionage
Act I have my mind a separate was that
called a subversion
it's additionally the internet Sedition
Act I have in mind a suspension of
habeas corpus these were not furious at
which subsequently we were
so some of the provisions in the
paperback which permitted incarceration
even of citizens as material witnesses
for prolonged years of time in isolation
from contact with their families or even
defense is troubling
I think the notion of the hostile
competent or whatever it's called yeah I
think all enemy enemy cumbersome is also
terribly elusive inve I just do think
that experimentation of this sort would
be lost its own that all not a desirable
posture and I'm rather drawn to your
idea of the temporary emergency act I
think that's a very good notion for
eating with what is a security problem
there's no doubt we thanks terrorism I'm
not saying we're not I'm just saying if
we want to deal with it that's not what
it is
that's not universalizing there's no
generalize it that's what creating more
enemies
let's not damage our democracy but by
all means let's focus on it and deal
with it politically as well as
militarily tonight that's just for one I
should say that this is one of the few
times that my newspaper writing actually
had an impact because this four-year
expiration of half the actus actually
comes out of that
week after 9/11 and is the dimension
that I want to generalize you see
because that putting it in there was to
identify at least part of the pig
tonight
I actually when it came out of the house
it was for two years in the whole life
was supposed to attire
as emergency legislation four years is
too long and what this this this
proposal of mine is this as it were
trying to build on that one positive
feature of the Patriot Act there are a
lot of battery subsidy features which
don't deserve recognition in any statute
whatever experience
raise your voice I tried to touch on
that in my presentation and I do address
it more than my book
hey I'm not attracted to that notion
because I think it's very important for
America indeed to have enduring friends
and during the viruses and I think
there's a lot in common that we have
with Europe in terms of values and
interest and that Europe also Japan and
the logical allies of the United States
temperate Park arrangement sometimes are
necessary that by and large they don't
provide the continuity and stability
that the other form of international
cooperation generates and some of the
expedient alliances than to be motivated
by entirely different calculations than
those that drive us and thus would
become unwitting tools in some respects
for example let's say of the Russian
suppression of the Chechens which the
Czech the Russians are proclaiming
loudly is part of the universal war
against terrorism and these days were
ever returning were chasing some
terrorists inevitably there are stories
in respect was that there are Chechens
among them and I think there's a risk of
that it creates unpredictability it
means that others from and if you
as a baby they are in fact I think some
of the effort to generate in this
country an anti-islamic hysteria is in
fact be motivated by deliberately
because there are countries in which it
isn't their interest for us to become
engage you know I'm limited warfare with
this one and then that creates a public
state of mind I haven't talked about
Nathan but I didn't Washington and what
struck me driving around Washington on
the Beltway some of you have done this
was something which really hit me but I
was a student at Harvard I was very much
interested in stammen ISM there one of
the things I studied was the campaign's
begins the enemies of the people which
are massive politically stimulated
hysteria implemented by terror signs all
over the place denouncing the enemies of
the people in Washington I find this
word unbelievable and shocking there are
electronic signs across their
flashlights actually do you buy and
would simply say the following report
suspicious activity
what kind of activity who are the people
who are engaging in suspicious activity
it doesn't take long in the kind of
panic atmosphere how these periodic
color alerts that you begin to say well
someone may be wearing a turban or a
veil or has a different color or has a
distinctive accent it's suspicious that
is the deliberate exploitation of fear
in order to generate political conduct
that is desirable and I found that very
threatening and ironic that's compatible
with a steady sustained commitment to
long-term global stability on the basis
of which you can also promote the global
common good and then institutionalize it
and I see that as a twin rolls of
America today the world promotion of
global stability collectively the
promotion of the global common good in
many ways has made the point that
terrorism across the world is not
necessarily uniform or related and that
terrorist organizations terrorist
manifestations at one part of the world
might made with there no relation at all
the terrace manifestations in another
make the point an example that
terrorists in ulster have nothing
against Mexico or Thailand however if
you go to holster now you'll see many
manifestations in Catholic areas of
Palestinian Flags in bas play and the
Protestant pubs in Austria tend to see
Israeli flags with with Hebrew and
English lettering
Israeli Defense Forces there's all kinds
of evidence this is true in other places
like like in Palestine and in the class
country that there are actual it goes
beyond the symbolism that there are
actual relationships between
organizations like the Irish Republican
Army and the PLO and so my question is
isn't there some truth in the uniformity
of terrorist organization insofar as at
least sometimes terrorist organizations
sympathise with each other and cooperate
with each other and shouldn't we as free
people below support liberal democracy
and peaceful means of negotiation try to
break that kind of approach indeed
neighbor and wealthy well there may be a
Finity I'm not sure that there is a
shared sort of global organizational
connection but even if there is affinity
it's in our interest to minimize it
rather tend to generalize it because
then we become more effective in dealing
with it so even if there is and the
problem will be more and more as this
firmament becomes more manifest it still
is not an interest to particularize it
and to deal with it in terms of the
specific settings because the last thing
we want is an interconnected global
terrorist network we have to be very
careful not to be contributing to it
through our own anxiety but also perhaps
being manipulated because it is also the
interest of some to get us involved in
every act of terror because then who
gains us as an ally and I'm not
particularly anxious to have there is an
imported into the United States from
various part of the world as an
extension of specific terrorist warfare
which then becomes focused on increasing
with the United States and I think we're
probably going to get some of that
because of what has been happening in
part because or what has been happening
in abilities specifically in you
I recognize those elements dominant
unless there is some external effort to
dampen the violence this is why the
clear articulation of what he's would
really entail will be the specific
arrangements what will be the quid pro
quos territorial human unities
arrangement is the mighty desire in
probably this stage among the
Palestinians to moderates are in the
minority yes in part because of the
continuous violence that's been
occurring for the last several years
throughout the [ __ ] world
I was saying the moderates are probably
in a significant majority still go
country by country yeah and there are
certain countries that we can define
those Islamic that are moving in a
positive direction actual Turkey's being
considered for membership in Europe 170
million people
contrary to with one reads in the United
States Press actually probably the next
candidate for the most serious evolution
change enforcement world is Iran which
is a serious country with a high level
of literacy an important role for women
in society consider degree of
sophistication with an increasingly
discredit the obviously entering is
thermidorian phase and I think after
Turkey if we play it right I think Iran
which is geopolitically located in a
very sensitive position as I tried to
suggest in my initial remarks could it
be that more promising country in terms
of change Morocco Tunisia go to mine
Jordan of the point some of the Emirates
and so the high places which are moving
to positive direction
but they're quite a few Islamic
countries which are still beset by
enormous internal problems in which they
lease hypocritical and self-serving in
which religious fundamentalism becomes
increasingly radical so the pictures of
next work but certainly not hopeless
certainly not one just deploying
formulations which carry with them the
implication of self-fulfilling
universalization which I think totally
because because project your voice one
criticism that's been leveled against
their current foreign policy is that one
of America's most powerful weapons is
the perception abroad of America is sort
of a peaceful sort of responsible nation
and that is a real problem but one has
to also be aware of the need for new
ones I think it's important that America
be viewed as a peaceful country and a
country respect international law it is
also a less important to America be
viewed as a powerful country prepared to
take action when it's necessary the
promise how to strike a balance between
the two and there have been periods of
time when America a lot in my view
excessively imminent and that this also
has negative consequences yeah I think
we have over corrected sense that's
dilemma today and this is why I'm so
keen on contributing if I can to a
serious national debate about foreign
policy which doesn't become an exchange
of sound bites or at hominem attacks
which doesn't take refuge in sweeping
demagogic formulations
I hope the debate is a serious
one hyena there it seriously troubled by
the fact this is believe me another
partisan statement that since 9/11 the
President of the United States has not
made in one single serious speech about
the international condition but has
relied largely on sloganeering
meaningless phrases which have anything
going to be deceptive such as axis of
evil whatever that means
or other slogans of this type in a
transparent imitation of Churchillian
but without
well I think you know the whole debate
over the war in Iraq was conducted than
the level of generality and that wasn't
consistent with reality I mean I think
it's very difficult to wage the war when
a phenomenon which you describe
essentially as it was a specter of some
sort rather than as a specific
manifestation connected with specific
problems located in specific areas of
the world and also connected with
specific historical experiences this is
what I find troubling example take a
look just on the speech a week ago in
the first anniversary of the war was a
gain from this kind of speeding
generality plus the assertion somehow
that the war in Iraq is actually step
forward in the war against terrorism
whereas in fact it's promised wanting
now more terrorism than before
you know he was showing us charts and
numbers 68% of Americans I'm glad
because yesterday The Wall Street
Journal said it was the worst idea in of
the year
but they might just what we just put out
a book we with the chip fish called
Liberation Day which is based on a large
number of studies that Jim and I have
done around the world in which random
samples 500 people one wasn't done in
New Haven actually last year when I was
away 500 people are coming to
Philadelphia let's say and generate
Jim asked them a whole series of
questions about Iraq they deliver it for
a day in a particular format and then
Jim asked them the same questions on the
facts and what they think and there's
quite a bit of change based on this we
argue for maybe the national holiday we
steal a president's pin put attributes
before the election in which Americans
are invited to let deliberate for a day
beginning with the national debate
between the candidates on for issues
specified before and then we is
completely practical we I even have
costs of school buses
it's not too much money actually nothing
for responsible citizenship and also
ex-ante that means that all these 3
billion dollars that we spend on
campaigns presidential election cycle
will not all be devoted to [ __ ] but
rather to prepare the conversation on
deliberation there as well as
constraints on the part of modern
government which is the manipulation of
asymmetric information I think that's
wrong a president has to know that the
four years down the line a couple of
these basic issues people are actually
going to talk about them for a day so
that's actually mean because the painful
fact is that established by 68d here so
far completed research is that Americans
and not only Americans know very little
about the most basic facts of policy and
yet as we've shown both as the jury
system would suggest and as efficient
delivery of deliberative polls
established they're quick learners at
the end of the day a tremendous increase
in sophistication occurs so we'll see
the US and Europe can work together and
actually together but it strikes me as
being possible that in the future there
is again an administration of the United
States level president that a unified
Europe would not support American
foreign policy because say the French in
position in would disagree and then end
up deciding again particularly different
or even opposing stance to that the US
and then the imposing stance would be
stronger than it is now just because the
nature of the information so how would
that be different from
well obviously if we continue with an
attitude to say to the Europeans if
you're not with us you're against us
you're increasing the probability that
they will be against us that's us share
the elemental simple common sense
Europeans happen to have rather similar
interests to ours in some key parts of
the world the expansion of Europe
eastward is in the interest of Europe
because it increases the zone of
stability I think that's not interest
the Europeans have a real interest in
peace in the Middle East because it's so
close to them I happen to believe that's
in our interest - not to mention the
Israelis and the Palestinians the
Europeans have an interest in the
Persian Gulf and in Iran not become an
explosive force I think that happens to
be our into a school given the impact
that Iran potentially has instability in
Iraq and in Afghanistan so I think we do
have shared interests not to mention
shared values more than in other parts
of the world so I think there is a basis
for a partnership but a partnership is
not an arrangement in which you dictate
and the test of friendship is that the
other side does exactly what we wish
especially we define it in somewhat
dogmatic and rather simplistic terms
which are a little difficult to digest
by people who are not altogether dinner
questions directions because I think
right now the president basic can not
apply our tenant excuse then write a
paper begin excuse that's given for what
happened regarding the misinformation on
the Iraq is essentially when everybody
thought so that's the first argument of
course the problem with that is who's
everybody
well other foreign governments did to
the question of course there is do they
have their own intelligence services
will be defending them then who are they
the fact is a lot of governments thought
that the Iraqis had weapons of mass
destruction because we told them we were
trusted Lewis thought he had a really
solid intelligence that had good record
over the years now that didn't turn out
to be sell well enough one why not say
publicly there was a failure of
intelligence and fire the people that
were responsible no in the native event
ships grace the bow come into port the
captain said
there is responsibility there's
accountability now why doesn't there
have ability here I'll give you a
hypothesis because if there's
accountability in summer this fire maybe
that'll say wait a minute
we didn't tell you with total certainty
that they had weapons of mass
destruction we did have footnotes which
introduced guns we didn't indicate large
areas of uncertainty the conclusions
that were drawn and presented to the
public went beyond what intelligence you
I started to spend that's the case so I
don't think there's gonna be any change
and then after the elections if the
outside party wins obviously the changes
with more dramatic but even at the
inside the current incumbent wins I
think they'll probably then change the
leadership of the agency I think they
will and I think there would be changes
because the people in power and honor
and intelligent people I mean there be
within that they're certainly
intelligent people and they know very
well that our intelligence was woefully
which south in the position of any
officer soldier went into Iraq maybe
their people missed wounds relatives
where in Iran they went to that country
which was said to have weapons of mass
destruction did any American officer
even American
to battle new therefore at what level
the Iraqi Armed Forces had Quattroporte
weapons of mass destruction was it on a
regimental level or was it on a brigade
level or was it on the level of division
what was the order of battle
what were the standard operating
techniques for the implementation of the
weapons of mass destruction comeback
these are the kind of things every
officer going to fight and perhaps dolly
against an enemy would want to know if
he stole the enemy has these weapons we
knew pretty well the Soviets had but in
this particular case the answer obvious
miss we didn't know so they were told
you're going to war against an enemy
armed with weapons of mass destruction
but we don't know what they have
enrichment level we don't know what they
have never gave level we don't know what
they have in divisional level we don't
know what their doctrine for implemented
the utilization of these weapons is well
there's an obvious disconnect here
there's an obvious lack of operational
intelligence and therefore I don't
believe the notion that there was a
total clear assertion
for our top leaders that Iraq was really
not with weapons of mass destruction
there were hypothetical guesses March
the base and the fact that we didn't
know what happened to a lot of stuff
after 1991 and therefore they might they
might not be but that's a very different
thing from saying we know that they have
weapons of mass destruction because if
you knew that then we should also know
where they are I was just reading them
right here today through the car from
New York blitz this book the US
government once he was told there all
these weapons of mass destruction
well talisman displaces your
intelligence where we should look and he
was given instructions where to look and
they went Lord and there weren't any in
these places and he explained that this
is one of the reasons he became
increasingly skeptical and thus the
issue of correcting our intelligence
dilemma is a very serious one but I
don't know
and why I means the killing well it's a
fair question to which I am not in a
position to give an answer because I
wasn't one of those flavor that decision
they all understand the motives of the
people who took it so you have to look
at the decision-makers and you have to
ask yourself what different combination
of motives was driving them and in all
product that it it says any decision is
always taken by a group of people there
are different motives for different
emotions but obviously they were quite
clearly driven by strong desire to
destroy Saddam Hussein and his regime
some perhaps to alter the Middle East in
some cases because Saddam was not nice
to somebody's daddy
maybe oil I mean maybe because he was a
bad guy which he certainly lost on the
problem is that have a lot of baptized
around the world and we're not touching
right now I think was a mixed set of
motives and I think it does raise a
serious problem because ultimately at
stake is a double issue credibility the
credibility of the United States in the
world and I've talked about that and
also the credibility of our own
government before our own people because
in our system there is an unspoken
covenant between the people and the
president and that covenant is that the
people have to trust the president to
take the right decisions in very great
moments but for that reason the
president has to be always reliable
you know that's a very serious issue
that's why I hope we have a serious
national discussion on this issue not
pointing towards accusations or abuse
but does raising the question whether
this has been an experience of which we
should be proud or which we should be
worried about and what are its
implications where our future over the
world
but also for how the public relies on
the government for taking decisions
sometimes when there's no time to
consult the country we have to build
trust
so it's make some really fundamental
issues that touch the very core
there's a question so this morning when
the Long Island Power Authority
announced this new energy bar suspect
because they increase gas prices and the
watchdog's came public immediately
saying that
lest I should be looking
alternative reusable sources of energy
more than just increasing food prices
every time
meteorologist still here self site-wide
one let's say somebody develops a
reusable brand-new reusable energy
source that's useful to everybody makes
steps towards sharing the booth with the
community so something is stoppable or
miss usable
how much would it change the geostrategy
but it would certainly reduce the global
significance of the Middle Eastern
region there's no doubt about that quite
August the point is however is not going
to happen the way you describe it
if it doesn't happen it'll happen
gradually but for the next 20 years I
don't think I have any series of
limitations of a fundamental change in
that respect so it does happen it will
happen over a period of time but there
for better or for worse we're stuck with
a lot of dependence so the actual games
saw the Chinese and Japanese and that
has strategic implications sir because
being a foolish having you with us this
afternoon thank you for